(laughs)
- It's a little flaccid.
- Mine has more girth.
(creaking)
(upbeat music)
- What are we eating?
- It's a Whopperrito, Ashley.
It's a Whopper as a burrito.
- That's what I thought,
and I was hoping it wasn't.
- I like burritos.
I like burgers.
I guess there's a chance
that the parts could be
greater than the sum,
or the sum could be
greater than the parts.
What's the saying?
- Is it like a burger in my burrito,
or is it a burrito in my burger?
- I feel like it's just
gonna taste like a burrito.
- I hope it tastes just like a burrito.
- Everything is trying to
become everything these days.
Instagram's trying to be Snapchat.
- Burger King's trying to
be Chipotle, apparently.
I hope I don't get E. Coli.
This is the laziest rolled burrito
I've ever seen in my life.
- So, is it literally
just like a Whopper--
- Are you gonna take it apart?
Ooh (groans).
It's just a smooshed up Whopper.
- It smells more like a burrito
than a burger, at this point.
- [Woman In Glasses] Yeah.
- I know that you're not supposed
to eat a burrito like this, by the way.
I just need to get to the middle of--
- You're eating it like corn on the cob.
Sure, why not?
You're not supposed to put a
burger in a burrito either,
so (beep) it.
- Oh.
- How does it taste?
- It tastes like a Whopper.
- Oh, I just taste tomatoes.
- It tastes just like a Whopper
with a tortilla around it.
- It's hamburger meat.
It's disorienting.
- How many calories is this?
Do we know?
- I don't wanna know the
nutrition facts, though.
I do not wanna know what's in it,
and how many.
I just said I don't wanna know.
- Yo, straight up,
this is delicious.
It has everything you want.
It is a burger
inside a burrito.
Just take my (beep) money.
- I think yeah, this is progression.
This is mixing cultures.
- Listen to me.
If a burger wants to
identify as a burrito,
who am I to say that it can't.
- People who wanna keep
a burger inside a burger,
you're holding this nation back, okay.
You can't hold back progress.
We're doing it, people.
- First, there was steel.
Then, there were railroads.
- [Both] Now, Whopperrito.
- Get used to this, guys.
This is the new America,
and it tastes not bad.
(instrumental music)
(creaking)